[Music]
last week due to the pandemic some
high-profile films were again postponed
on the one hand this affects Matt Reeves
the Batman which will be delayed by a
few months before it is released in
cinemas in the US on October 1st 2021
also DC's new movie the flash is
affected but this one has been pushed
forward by one months and is now
scheduled to be released in early June
2022 The Sopranos sequel the sames of
New York has also been pushed back a few
months and is now scheduled to be
released in March 2021
while the release of Will Smith drama
King Richard has been delayed by a whole
year to November 2021 the still nameless
Elvis Presley movie starring Tom Hanks
has been pushed back by just one month
to november 2021 according to current
information Christopher Nolan's Tennant
in Wonder Woman 1984 both which are
scheduled for release in a few months
are not postponed to what extent this
will actually happen remains to be seen
we will of course keep you informed
about further delays from the film world
even before the Batman was postponed
from summer to fall 2021 director Matt
Reeves gave a short interview to Daily
Beast among other things it became clear
that the 53 year old filmmaker wanted to
give the new Batman a very personal
touch and even managed to make the
superhero film stand out from its
predecessors when asked how he wanted to
highlight the film Reef's drew a
parallel between his Planet of the Apes
franchise and Batman because they have
one thing in common both were the
directors dream project he literally
said the way I love Apes is the way that
I love Batman actually the only two
French as that might have been something
I would have connected with amazing the
other ones I was approached by it's been
a very special thing I can't say about
almost any other franchise that they
would have been the right fit for me
moreover the director also hints that
the pause created by the coronavirus
could prove to be quite advantageous for
the movie because whenever he thinks
back to his past movies he always find
something positive about the time they
had a production standing still it
remains to be seen when the production
of the Batman which last took place in
London can be continued the new release
date of the Batman is supposed to be on
October 1st 2021 a few days ago a new
picture of the Jurassic world set was
published on Twitter surprisingly it
doesn't show a tropical island like most
of the offshoots but a snowy landscape
which is untypical fully Jurassic world
series at least that's what the picture
by a director call
trevorrose suggests who posted this
picture is part of a Twitter trend of
celebrities at work fans of the
franchise however will probably be more
interested in the fact that the new
Jurassic world film will take place at
least partially in ice and snow an
appearance of t-rex and Coen the icy
landscape is rather unrealistic
according to the current state of
science there were far fewer dinosaurs
living in the Arctic and most of their
fossils have not even been found yet
apart from the change in landscape there
also other news namely the published
picture shows Macy Lockwood played by
Isabella sermon if you want to know more
about Lockwood's background story you
should definitely take a look at the
second part of Jurassic world the
release date of Jurassic world Dominion
is currently June 11th 2021 currently
due to the virus all video streams of
the common providers run with a reduced
bitrate this also applies to the
streaming giant Netflix which has
announced that its streams will be
throttled for 30 days for the time being
this period has now already expired for
some time will remain for the time being
as the company confirmed on request
similarly competitors Amazon Prime video
and Disney Plus are also continuing to
apply the same measures so what the
major providers all have in common is
that they currently require less
bandwidth and therefore pay less in
short the streaming providers saved a
lot of money in corona times while
Amazon Prime video and Apple TV plus for
example provide high quality content at
no extra cost
Netflix charges significantly more for
it even those who only want a normal HD
resolution have to pay more not to
mention 4k according to Gollum to eat
Netflix claims that the reduction in
quality is only very slight and that
it's only noticeable to people who value
the highest possible video quality in
our own opinion however we're currently
seeing a noticeable worse picture quite
often compared to the time before the
restrictions especially for Netflix the
critical question has to be allowed when
the visible quality will be raised to
the regular value again especially for
those customers who pay a surcharge for
a higher resolution and thus also for
higher quality have you noticed the loss
of quality which streaming service do
you use and who do you think is the best
quality at the moment please let us know
in the comments
up to now Hollywood has not really had
much success in the field of manga and
anime
nevertheless the mostly very imaginative
series from the far east still enjoyed
great popularity and while there's
currently a one-piece and a Cowboy Bebop
live-action at
chan being worked on Sony Pictures is
already working on a film adaption off
one punch man the origins of one punch
man lie in the Japanese webcomic by the
artist one which has been running since
2009 has also been converted into an
anime in 2015 this story revolves around
Saitama who one day decides to become a
hero after years of training the good
Saitama has to struggle with circular
Hallows but in return can also finish
off his opponents with a single punch
the story is a mixture of superhero
tribute and a bit of parody and so it is
supposed to be adapted for a live-action
movie the film one punch man will be
made by Arad Productions which is named
after the co-founder of the Marvel
Studios and is also managed by him
venom authors Jeff Pinkner and Scott
Rosenberg are responsible for the script
the duo not only wrote the story for
venom for Sony Pictures but also the
screenplay for the two new Jumanji films
pink Paris also be executive producer of
the other anime live action version of
Cowboy Bebop even if you're a die-hard
anime fan who is very critical of the
real-life adaption you won't be able to
deny that at least the right people are
involved in the project unfortunately a
release date for the one punch man real
adaption hasn't been fixed yet further
news are also available for fans of Neon
Genesis Evangelion who after an
eight-year wait for the final film of
the rebuild of evangelion franchise
which was scheduled for June 27th 2020
now have to wait even longer due to the
pandemic however to cheer up fans a bid
the responsible studio studio Kara has
announced to make the first three movies
of the series available for free on
their official YouTube channel until
April 30th it should be noted however
that only the Japanese version with
English subtitles can be found there the
rebuild of evangelion franchise started
in 2007 with Evangelion 1.0 and function
as a reboot of the original series Neon
Genesis Evangelion from 1995 but while
the first movie covered the first five
episodes of the original series the
second movie Evangelion 2.0 completely
stood out and also introduced new
characters the last movie of the series
Evangelion 3.0 was released in 2012 but
a new release of the final movie of the
series Evangelion 3.0 plus 1.0 has yet
to be announced
because so far it's only known that it
will be postponed
[Music]